[Musique]
bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau c'est 8 le journal voici
les titres
le ministre des affaires étrangères jean
marc ayrault et l'ambassadeur du mexique
était au château de la celle-saint-cloud
samedi dernier à l'occasion de
l'inauguration de l'oeuvre chicogrande
dès le premier temple france est mort
moi ouvert ses portes jeudi dernier au
chesnay près de vingt ans après le
lancement du projet le lieu de culte
ravira les trente mille fidèles que
compte l'hexagone
et puis vendredi dernier a eu lieu
l'animation les gamer en vacances à la
médiathèque du canal à montigny le
bretonneux
l'événement gratuit a permis de
rassembler famille et à mes amis durant
cette période de vacances scolaires il
n'y a pas eu des preuves du permis de
conduire aujourd'hui dans les yvelines
et à paris cela fait suite à l'agression
violente d'un inspecteur vendredi au
centre d'examen de vélizy villacoublay
les inspecteurs du permis de conduire se
sont réunis au centre de la ville pour
rencontrer leurs administrations exiger
des changements alors ce qu'on demande
par exemple pour le centre de vélizy où
ça s'est passé c'est une surveillance
vidéo de façon à dissuader les gens qui
voudraient malheureusement je laisse les
inspecteurs de reculer un peu le ne pas
faire de passer à l'acte du coup qui
seront filmés et puis ensuite on
voudrait aussi un vigile à l'entrée de
du centre du visible pour filtrer
l'entrée des personnes qui accèdent au
centre parce que joe d'aujourd'hui la
barrière est ouvert et n'importe qui
peut rentrer inauguration le 8 avril
dernier au château de la
celle-saint-cloud de l'oeuvre
chicogrande et du sculpteur mexicain
javier marine
la cérémonie s'est déroulée en présence
du ministre des affaires étrangères jean
marc ayrault et de juan manuel gomez
robledo l'ambassadeur du mexique javier
mas winne est notamment connu pour ses
sculptures en bronze chicogrande et
c'est le nom de cette oeuvre que
l'artiste mexicain javier marine donne à
la france
cette sculpture en bronze mesure
vingt cinq mètres de long elle a pris
place dans le jardin du château de la
celle-saint-cloud propriété du quai
d'orsay est aussi lieu d'exposition
c'est une grande fierté et je remercie
d'ailleurs le 1010 d'avoir mis en valeur
touche la dimension culturelle du
domaine l'artiste mexicain a réalisé
toute une série de ses dettes énormes
qui sont exposés ailleurs dans le monde
des visages inspiré d'un peuple
précolombien où l'on retrouve aussi
certains traits occidentaux un concentré
d'histoire mexicaine en somme la nation
mexicaine et qui chute de ce syncrétisme
entre les cultures précolombiennes et
les cultures européennes et ses
sculptures à symbolise dans une large
mesure ce métissage des relations
diplomatiques entre la france et le
mexique battent leur plein une
exposition consacrée à l'art mexicain
s'est tenue récemment au grand palais et
la france sera bientôt l'invité
d'honneur d'un festival d'art vivant au
mexique
je pense que c'est une manière de
rapprocher les peuples et nous sommes
dans une période tellement incertaine
que et dangereuse qui est important de
rapprocher les peuples et tout ce qui
peut y contribuer comme cet événement
d'aujourd'hui va dans la bonne direction
pour découvrir l'oeuvre le public devra
attendre le 18 avril prochain où les
journées européennes du patrimoine
et ce week-end aussi une marche des
oublis organisée par l'association des
paralysés de france a eu lieu quatre
personnes en situation de handicap ont
pris la route de nantes pour rejoindre
paris en bike nous les avons rencontrés
lors de leur étape à versailles
un reportage de nicolas d'entrée
nantes paris hand bike c'est le défi de
nicolas jean pierre philippe et yoann
quatre militants de l'association des
paralysés de france
parti le 25 mars une quarantaine de
kilomètres parcourus chaque jour et sont
accueillis par la délégation des
immigrants fierté parce que je pense
qu'ils ont énormément de courage qu'ils
ont entrepris quand même ça fait c'est
un projet d'envergure mais sa porte haut
et fort les couleurs des personnes
handicapées qui se battent pour eux mais
aussi pour tous les autres pour toutes
les personnes aient oublié en chemin
pour toutes les personnes en précarité
à chaque étape de cette marche citoyenne
des oubliés ils s'arrêtent dans une
ville pour discuter échanger les
distribuer leurs tracts je avec
mes bras j'ai une aide électrique sur
mon vélo pour les monter et non c'est un
projet vraiment magnifique
sait on est partis de nantes et on va
rencontrer beaucoup de personnes
quand même 400 et quelques kilomètres
dans les bras pendant légende comme
dirait l'autre
mais les rencontres qu'on fait font
qu'on peut repartir le lendemain
objectif de cette action faire entendre
leurs revendications autour du respect
des libertés fondamentales de
l'accessibilité au droit ou encore de
l'inclusion sociale
on va rencontrer les candidats
à leur qg pour leur remettre nos
propositions apf et pour se faire
représenter par toutes les autres
associations qui travaillent contre
toutes les formes d'exclusion
à peine le temps d'échanger avec les
versaillais nicolas jean pierre philippe
et yoann repartent arrivée à paris
prévue ce mardi 11 avril à 14h au
trocadéro pour un rassemblement citoyen
près de vingt ans après le lancement du
projet les mormons de france ont enfin
inauguré le premier temple hexagonal
c'était jeudi dernier au chesnay un lieu
de culte qui ravira les 38 le fidèle co
compte l'hexagone sous un soleil estival
l'église de jésus-christ des saints des
derniers jours non officiel des mormons
ouvre les portes de son premier temple
en france
la congrégation compte déjà une centaine
l'église mormone dans l'hexagone nous
attendons ce moment depuis longtemps
les membres de l'église ici en france
ils ont l'occasion d'aller au temple à
madrid doit en suisse mais finalement
nous avons un temple vraiment ici aux
chaînés cinq ans de travaux ont été
nécessaires pour construire ce site de
9000 m² comprenant le temple accessible
aux seuls mormons et un grand jardin
ouvert au public
selon la mairie du chesnay le chantier
aurait coûté 80 millions d'euros environ
entièrement financée par l'église
mormone ce site nous a plu dès le début
parce que c'est un endroit très calme
c'est un endroit paisible je crois que
les ville du chesnay et les villes de
versailles sont des villes extrêmement
calme paisible pour ceux qui
souhaiteraient découvrir ce culte et
l'édifice sera ouvert au public pendant
trois semaines du 22 avril au 13 mai de
9h à 21h
c'est un très bel édifice où ce sont
quelque part isolé du monde
nous y venons tous l'étude blanc pour un
moment de prière et de méditation
dans un lieu hautement spirituel pour
les autorités mormone ce premier temple
en france n'a pas vocation à attirer de
nouveaux fidèles
il devrait toutefois faciliter la vie
des trente huit mille mormons de france
qui devaient jusque là se rendre dans un
temple en suisse pour se faire baptiser
ou se marier
le triton crêté était à l'honneur ce
week end à la réserve naturelle
nationale de saint quentin en yvelines
à l'occasion de la 23e édition de
fréquence grenouille
le public a pu découvrir l'amphibien et
les richesses des zones humides
retour sur cet après midi ludique
donc qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur cet
animal quand on l'observé comme ça elle
la mission de ces enfants connaître le
triton crêté pour en devenir un aussi il
participa fréquence grenouille et vont
découvrir cet animal protégé
c'est une espèce mais en voie de
disparition malheureusement comme
beaucoup dans fille bien ici mais aussi
à travers le monde et c'est bien pour ça
qu'il faut les protéger
elle est préservé et c'est pour vraiment
sensibiliser éduquer les enfants mais
aussi les parents à cette protection de
ces espèces très importante et qui sont
vraiment qui évoluent dans ces milieux
et l'aquatique et terrestres si tu étais
un un triton serial tirer ou toi dans
les temps là un plein d'eau la petite
main le jeu pensé par la réserve de
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines veut faire découvrir la
nécessité de protéger les zones humides
pour conserver sa biodiversité est très
très bien le monsieur il était très très
bien voilà il y avait un petit groupe
laon ça s'est bien passé avec le soleil
impeccable à il fallait faire des
mouvements avec les pattes avant et les
pattes arrière est ce qu'on est des
tritons j'ai aidé a déjà à trouver lait
les pâtes les empreintes et tout ça
j'essaye de donner quelques réponses qui
sait pas bien de polluer les eaux pour
les amphibiens et tous les autres
un set les participants ont pu profiter
d'une ouverture exceptionnelle
la réserve naturelle n'est accessible
que quelques jours par mois dans le
monde plus de 50% des zones humides ont
disparu au cours du siècle dernier
redonner confiance aux jeunes des
quartiers populaires à travers le sport
tel était l'objectif du cyclo-défi cette
course de vtt à travers les yvelines
s'est terminée vendredi dernier à
versailles pour sidonie et bang à la
coordinatrice
le pari est réussi très difficile je
pense que le terme est minime 1
franchement il est il est tout petit
très vite si un autre terme au dessus de
très difficile c'est vrai celui-là mais
vraiment ça a été une épreuve pénible un
dur pour les jeunes et vendredi dernier
l'heure était aussi au jeu vidéo à la
médiathèque du canal à montigny le
bretonneux l'animation baptisé les gamer
en vacances a permis aux amis et aux
familles de passer un moment convivial
pour ce jeu en fait faut juste prendre
la manette et l'appui mais dans le sens
qu'on veut ok ils sont attentifs mais
connaissent déjà les règles du jeu les
jeunes gamers ne sont jamais vraiment en
vacances à saint quentin en yvelines sur
playstation 4 ou sur wii une dizaine
d'enfants s'opposer s'amusent pendant
plus d'une heure ce jour-là il incarne
notamment à rayman héros virtuel qui
doit sauver le monde face à mr d'arc et
peuvent aussi découvrir des nouveautés
plutôt ludique on arrive à connaître nos
défauts nos avantages on se parle
en plus aux jeunes de tester un jeu j'ai
très bien j'appelle fourrure et en fait
on eu le vent prend des pétales et on
doit verdir des ennuis avec ses pétales
sont pratiquement ceux qui n'ont pas de
jeu chez eux
j'ai mauvais toulon ces ateliers jeux
vidéo sont proposés à chaque vacances
scolaires par le réseau des médiathèques
de l'agglomération à partir de 6 ans et
sans limite d'âge
l'occasion de jouer à plusieurs plutôt
que seuls à la maison
l'objectif c'est passer un moment de
détente un moment de loisir et c'est
aussi découvrir le monde des jeux vidéo
alors on propose des jeux sur notre
échelle des jeux sont à vif et on
sélectionne différents jeux il essaie
vraiment de jouer en groupe et on peut
s'entraider dans le jeu l'inscription
pour participer à ces après midi est
obligatoire via le site internet des
médiathèques la prochaine session est
prévue pour mercredi 12 avril
[Applaudissements]
ce week end l'équipe de football de
trappes recevez plus tôt un match qui
n'a pas tenu toutes ses promesses en
effet les deux équipes se sont
neutralisées 1 partout écoutez arnaud et
bizi l'entraîneur de l'équipe senior de
lestrade logique un match équilibré où
chaque chaque équipe a eu son tampon
entre guillemets moi j'essaie fermé où
chaque équipe avait dix ans j'ai un peu
différent donc tout le parti des points
c'est un match assez fermé où tous les
contacts un peu après vous présente le
dur à voir donc ces résultats qui commet
logique c'est la fin de ce cette ut le
journal merci de nous avoir suivis et
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]